in five four three two one
welcome everybody to another episode of
genius brain podcast I'm your host David
so and we have a very special guest we
have the Latina booty heat and I only
say that because I literally see her ass
every day on Instagram the [ __ ]
peaches on this [ __ ] always leave some
comment like I need to recreate this
picture and you've never done it first
of all because you have so many I don't
know which one to do I call you [ __ ]
the Georgia left Tina peach hey
everybody it's me my name is ass we're
gonna be doing a podcast I just asked
you say that you have a special guest on
every time depending because I noticed
that you said it just now and I just I
want to feel like I'm actually special
but I feel that you may say that you
know what the funny thing is actually
never hung out what they're like
one-on-one before I know I just I just
know that you were around the barbel
people it's not you're really funny yes
and I just are falling when I say oh
look at this girl dude she had the
[ __ ] booty and then recently we were
DMing each other and I basically was
like [ __ ] Frick like whoa whoa whoa
it's like gonna unlock something but I
didn't like this girl's [ __ ] mad
funny dude like we should probably kick
it sometime she goes Beauty no idea what
[ __ ] best friends [ __ ] on man I
try to [ __ ] block remember she's so
much I got a new number went into the
deep web right now basically own
Davidson now you're on my podcast
I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] why do you think I'm
here I ended up here so I don't know
[ __ ] about you so I'm actually using
this time to actually get to know you
Luther
just because why the [ __ ] not dude dude
I saw that you did you did like a hobby
ASMR thing oh my god yeah that's why so
me coming in here right now and saying
this whole setup I'm like yeah I started
an ASMR channel and I'm about to like
kill that [ __ ] do you know what a smart
stands for auto sensory meridian
response good because I had no idea I
was nasty you like my [ __ ] deal I
actually had no idea I thought you were
gonna try and make me seem no but I know
my [ __ ] so what's your wish a top three
favorite ask Marcia
as in like people that I like to watch
art the actual sensation the actual
sincere okay
I love roleplay kinky I know roleplay is
like there's like cranial nerve exam
videos or there's relaxing facial at the
spa or a haircut those are my favorite
because it's a mixture of like personal
attention but also the sounds of what
the [ __ ] do some of these ASMR they're
popping all these channels they're
[ __ ] crazy my favorite right now
actually is chiropractic back crack's
you know I did a video I did a video
night I know you did because I watch
chiropractic videos and I saw you in our
videos get out of your dude wait so you
found it so I think that's how that
video it ended up going viral for me at
least because my videos do not get
anywhere near a million views and that
video I titled it what an hour with my
chiropractor looks like yeah and it was
like a million views and the comments
were just like oh my god this was so
satisfying did I and I just posted it I
see that's that's [ __ ] up that you
find that you know what satisfied and
your roleplay ASMR as a [ __ ] you [ __ ]
judge yo something about watching
somebody get their back crack makes me
feel like I'm being relieved because I
know how great it feels to get your back
correct you know you know I mean like
it's that's what that whole experience
is is that you watch somebody get their
[ __ ] done and it makes you feel like
you're getting your [ __ ] done that's
interesting I never thought of it from
that perspective for me like I
personally love getting my bad crack
don't get me wrong like that shit's bomb
but if I'm listening to it I don't know
it just sounds painful
it sounds more painful to me and then
like do they make sounds you know like
the person's getting their back cracked
will they go like oh no but sometimes
afterwards they have a sigh of relief oh
my gosh I get that yeah okay cuz you're
like experiencing that that's what it is
but the
my second top favorite is actually
Indian face massage a head massages have
you seen that [ __ ] no it is the funniest
[ __ ] bugger because because these
Indian dudes that it looks good at first
they start going into the shoulder they
start rubbing the head in this very
unique way then they start slapping the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of all you've never
seen it I'm gonna show you a side of an
Indian ASMR [ __ ] wait this is real
this real [ __ ] like I guess like you can
get it at barber shops there but there's
a couple of dudes that just go in there
I'm talking about so they'll get the
class their hands together and they'll
start tapping the head I don't know they
start [ __ ] slapping the [ __ ] [ __ ]
out of them and it number one it makes
me laugh it also makes me feel relaxed
because a part of me it looks like it
feels good there's a reason why I do go
and get back then I have a [ __ ] fat
head that's why we can't work with these
condition no I don't think so okay what
are so if those are your two what are
your other like what's your next the
next thing is I just started getting
into it so I have a bit of insomnia so I
have a lot of trouble sleeping like it's
been something that's ongoing and the
reason why I got into ASMR [ __ ] is
because help me sleep yeah same here
right so I started listening to the
chiropractor back crack's because I
started knocking me the [ __ ] out it was
the weirdest thing I know you're
probably you probably woke up the next
morning like what did I thought my
girlfriend was gonna leave me when she
saw me dude I would watch it so
intensely and she would wake up she goes
are you [ __ ] watching porn next to me
are you jacking off on laying next to in
bed and I my baby watch porn go watch
porn you sick [ __ ] but I started
watching like these days some are back
rest oh let me sleep and now I'm into
adult bedtime stories so they speak very
calmly Asaf it's like a form of ASMR but
I don't think they label it as ASMR but
it's adult bedtime story what about it
what's the adult fact I because it's not
about like fluffy bunnies Oh eating
carrots sounds so interesting it's
[ __ ] company you should do that [ __ ]
okay so okay that's been my biggest
thing with my channels like there's so
many different things that can
done and everybody's done the tapping
and everyone idle and I'd like to talk I
can't shut the [ __ ] up ever so I want to
have something that is like that I love
that like if I could just create some
old short stories I was going to read
whatever you want on YouTube
I mean I think I think the the thing
that I [ __ ] up on on YouTube I would
say [ __ ] up because it's what I wanted
to do anyways but if I was let's say ten
years younger right and I was 20 years
old I would probably just not set a
format for my channel and do whatever
the [ __ ] I wanted so originally for me
because I wanted to be a stand-up comic
everything was based around comedy I
still do stand-up comedy so I was 16
yeah when do you can I come well I've
been taking a fat break because I'm
working on this podcast now okay you
know I start doing film so yes yes yes I
took a huge break off and up and I'm
next year I'm imma do stand-up probably
full-time just a game I really didn't
know that I want to go see your [ __ ]
funny funny yo but let me so I just had
a stand-up show recently out in [ __ ]
Michigan right it doesn't have been like
a couple years and I was like yeah I
still got some sets in my [ __ ] head I
should probably I should be fine oh I
didn't tank but there was a lot of jokes
that I knew the set up and the hit for
that I thought I still remembered and I
would just say a joke cuz like cuz you
know when I don't know kids that save me
because they help me remember my set as
I was speaking to people which is what
you know it's just crowd work [ __ ] dude
I was like dude I am out of practice
that would stress me out
that's whatever dude well is it well not
do my first and I'm sure I got booed
when I was like 16 years old and all
rightfully so I sucked I would have
booed myself if I had a time machine I
would go back in time have a ripe tomato
and throw it but when you were 16 did
you think that you suck did you actually
think that the jokes you had were
funnier they were good or did you know
if I thought I mean I I thought I was
funny because people told me I was funny
right so when I did that stand-up show
it was it was at a [ __ ] local church
because they had like the stand-up night
and I said why not it's in a comfort you
know
comfortable area so I decided to do it
yo you talk about some Christians that
boo huh hold on you christ-like [ __ ] I
was like y'all I'm doing it but it
wasn't really it was at the church and
the the the venue was rented out of the
church so I [ __ ] up in thinking that
it was like a church stand-up comedy
night because my father's a pastor so I
wasn't oh it's gonna be warming with the
love of Christ there was some demons in
there that I didn't give a [ __ ] about my
16 year old feelings yeah I remember too
cuz I was crushed he's gonna acid you
cry I would have cried I think I would
have cried but I didn't bud off a stage
your first time I didn't cry actually
what I was mortified first of all I and
then after that that feeling went away
but then I just started going again and
again and then and you just get better
and the reason why is because I'm a 16
year old kid talking to an adult
audience about adult [ __ ] that I don't
know about so rightfully so I should get
[ __ ] me what the [ __ ] do you know and
you know at that time when you're super
young you don't even know what you're
saying you're just modeling your stuff
off of your favorite comics and you're
really just biting their material yeah
and I started to realize like yo I'm not
as original as I thought it was like I'm
just a kid biting off of my favorite
people like Eddie Murphy and all these
other dogs so I was like oh maybe I
should chill out a bit and work on my
own [ __ ] and talk about my own life
experience instead instead of talking
about situational [ __ ] I don't even know
about so that's why when you get older
your standard gets better right you just
have more stories more experience
exactly so now that I'm older like I'm
[ __ ] stand-up she's four days you
know so now I just have to rework it and
see how was good I mean I don't know if
I'll be great at it but I'm I was good
enough to do what I'm doing now so I
literally respect people that do
stand-up comedy so much because like I
know so many people that are hilarious
but there's there is a difference
between just like casually being funny
and actually being able to produce a
bunch of different jokes and get a whole
crowd laughing and I just I wouldn't
even begin to understand what the
pattern would be to write out a joke
realize where the hit is gonna be if
it's gonna get the laugh and then what
do you do for you don't get the laugh
what if your mind it should have gotten
alive and it didn't get the lot well you
have to make a choice is is this joke
not funny or is did I not present it
right or is the crowd you say
a bad night so you have to make that
choice right so there's a lot of times
where like I'll to rework jokes like in
my early 20s and I reworked it and then
I was like it would have been funnier if
I did this I tried it out and I was like
hold on a second it was funny it was
funnier the other way around [ __ ] that I
went back and I did it a third time and
another set and it [ __ ] killed so you
know you just really have to gauge
certain things you know so interesting
that it's hard right yeah and also like
your audience is gonna change state to
state city to city you don't just also
just oh my god oh dude I did a Michael
Jackson joke not too receptive some
people do not find Kitty diddlers okay
so we don't find but touching funny huh
yeah gotcha cool all going to scratch I
didn't scratch it off I was like
different crowd it was funny baby laughs
[ __ ] you guys I guarantee if you did any
of this in like the United Kingdom
everything would be a hit they have the
most dark humor your fur i watch so this
is UFC fighter named Michael Bisping
right and this cat dude he's he's
[ __ ] savages hell he's not even a
stand-up comic but he could be but even
the way he speaks he's so harsh and he
was just saying that's how everybody is
well like everybody just [ __ ] roasts
each other all the time I'm telling you
I was when I was working with this
company one of the photographer's became
a really good friend
he lived in Manchester Birmingham
something like that and one of our first
interactions he was like you stupid
[ __ ] [ __ ] and it was like oh I'm
sorry I'm sorry he's like ah you're
great like I just want you to know
you're stupid if I can go I'm like wow I
could not believe it this is so
refreshing it is so refreshing he's like
your fat [ __ ] and I was like f Nikoli
or born and reborn risk I was born in
San Francisco oh you a frisco [ __ ] wait
and Riley was Riley if you guys don't
know what you probably don't is my
roommate and best friend who loves David
so Riley if you're listening hey uh
Riley was saying that he thinks you're
from Sacramento I have a gentleman what
I'm sac town baby now I was six home he
was good oh my god yeah we literally had
argument about it this morning I was
like he's not he's from LA and he goes
no I'm pretty sure he's from Sacramento
watch you're gonna say this on the
podcast
Riley you [ __ ] it's true oh man dude
honestly don't of times you harass that
dude on your story is [ __ ] funny
Larry you know it's wrong like it's so
bad because me and chachi one of my best
friend's she's like caught on to it now
and we're just like if anybody saw the
things that we do to him
oh my god like it would be so it would
be so controversial but the thing is god
there's no way to justify that he's my
best friend okay and he does very
controversial things
so wait chachi is she's a dancer yeah
she's she is engaged to it she to a guy
that came on Jake he news oh he did Yuka
Yuka that's right so he had a prank
channel with us yeah yeah they're
engaged yeah he was married he was and
now he's not so but he won't be again so
he split and then yes so basically their
whole relationship basically like he was
married to somebody in finland and then
she was at the time dating somebody else
and then they went on this show and
things changed and then they came back
it was that that the [ __ ] show
climbing up a mountain that she met yeah
be on the show you were yeah I was
supposed to be on the show but that I
was contracted to Kevin Hart's Network
at the point that time so I couldn't get
out of that contract to go there what a
bummer to be contracted to Kevin hurt
like Wow nothing came out of it alright
okay oh is this the app yeah they are
hearing about that yeah there were a lot
of people what ended up happening with
that well a lot of stuff just didn't
happen that's sad you know it is what it
is sounded so cool I mean that's no
knock the Kevin Hart I mean he it's just
it's you know he's doing his own thing
and he has his own staff you know it's
just it didn't go through a lot of
really came a lot of people were pretty
pissed about it to be honest yeah and
you know for me to like I was like
attractive like two years great so then
it's like all these different
opportunities that you weren't and I
could have been climbing up a mountain
and I could be [ __ ] I could be
married to you right now you can engage
you can I got [ __ ] way
right yeah I would have left my
girlfriend girlfriend and just you know
on the side exactly that's right so no
they had basically you know they met on
that show and then after when their
relationships and stuff ended then it
was like hey I kind of like kind of
controversial how old is catotti yeah it
is uh chachi is 22 or 23 and usually
just an embryo what you were like just
yesterday you were an embryo yeah dude
wait so what am I then if I'm 24 am i
you still a [ __ ] baby dude it's
[ __ ] crazy she's a lot younger than I
thought she was yeah and I think Yuka is
in his late 30s or early 40s oh [ __ ]
damn dude you know what's so weird like
I never know how to feel about those
type of AIDS and the reason why is
because I don't like let's say for me
I'm 30 years old right yeah like I don't
even if I talk to like a 20 year old
girl I don't know what the [ __ ] we talk
about right right cuz that what's life
experience it's like you just finished
your SATs like I don't know like what
are we gonna talk about girl you know
it'll be like yeah cuz like you worried
about your world history test like I'm
over here John you know trying to but
then at the same time I look at somebody
like chachi she's been forced to grow up
like a lot earlier she's been through so
much in a life too that has matured her
yeah so it's like maybe they do have a
lot to talk about so Yuka is like think
of what's the guy from Janice what's
that you know who I'm talking to Steve
oh yeah he's like that and so at the
same time like you cos maturity he is he
does have the maturity of an older man
because he is one but he also very much
so has a kid very much so alive in him
and so I feel that with chachi's life
experiences and with you cos childlike
yeah energy then it kind of makes the
relationship pop how do you go have kids
he has two kids how they I they're young
they're like four and five because
that'd be weird if you cuz kids were the
same age I'd be a great Will Ferrell
movie that [ __ ] it would be [ __ ] wild
why Will Ferrell I don't know some mommy
sister
I would have been [ __ ] that's great
you know what like I feel like well I'm
not really like perusing on YouTube that
much but I feel like people would've
made a big [ __ ] deal it was it was a
very big deal and I feel like just
recently excited that it's it's starting
to subside I mean what you gonna do kids
like what the [ __ ] are you gonna do
right right there together yeah like you
say stuff put them up well it was also
like it was a mixture of her previous
relationship and the fact that she was
now with an older guy and so people were
just really upset and so I think she I
was that's when her and I were just
starting to get close and she's like I
put up this video today basically just
saying like guys can you please just let
us be in a relationship because change
you know because I don't even think she
has to explain anything it's like it's
my business dude the dick I suck is the
dick that's a biblical verse I don't
understand like what's the what's it to
you you know what I think you know I
understand from a fan base point because
they they do get emotionally invested in
specific so like you know what you know
I say that but I understand I get it a
hundred percent and you want the best
for this person so it's almost like they
grew up with you since they were little
kids they looked up to you and they see
you in their minds [ __ ] up and they
want to help you solve that right they
really do want to help you and the hard
part about that is just like how do you
go from I want to help somebody that I
look up to to I own you and you should
do what I tell you right it's like is it
emotional investment or is it a control
thing where you feel that it's almost
like the people online become like a pet
to you where you just like no you can't
do that you can't do this you can't you
know it can be kind of twisted in that
way if people become a little possessive
over your career which is kind of like I
just I can't I kind of understand but I
don't at the same time because like for
me it's like well you you came on to my
platform falling whatever I was doing it
was my choice right
so either way so why would you force my
artistry or whatever that I did
something else you wouldn't want to
follow me anyway totally that actually
reminds me because when you were just
talking about earlier how you feel that
the one mistake that you made or one
thing you wish you could have changed
was basically not having such a set yeah
for your channel
and that's kind of something that I'm
kind of going through right now and with
the comments of other people following
me for one thing and turning into an
what just came out of my [ __ ] mouth I
don't know those words I was this list
they were words but they were what I was
trying to say like equals Thursday
honestly please copyrighted by me though
and give me 30% of profit actually make
it 70 okay so as I was saying um YouTube
yeah and content and getting in one
direction people following you for one
thing switching it up whatever that's
something that I did like I started as a
fitness channel and after it took me
like two years for me to be like oh [ __ ]
I actually like to talk about other
things and I want to post about other
things I'm Fitness aside from Fitness
yeah because it's such a I mean in
general we all so much about ourselves
that we want to share and so I'm in that
boat right now where I am uploading
whatever I want because I want to and if
people don't like it then it is what it
is sucks and how long have you been
doing youtube I always say this wrong I
always think it's been like 2 years but
I think it's been like 4 or 5 now ok
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's been a long
time and I mean a long time to me for
yeah I was probably 19 or 20 when I quit
my job and then started doing youtube
full-time so what did you do before I
worked at a salon I was a hair stylist
but I wouldn't know I wasn't like really
a hair stylist though I was just kind of
like an assistant ok so you just you
just clean up the hair no I did blow
drys okay
they you said blow drives thank God I
did blow drys I yeah I did go to school
I got my license and I was doing makeup
I had a YouTube channel on a separate
platform I mean on YouTube it was just
like a separate channel and that was a
beauty related videos but that never
really went anywhere and we're doing it
I loved it yeah but it was also just so
saturated you know at the time beauty
gurus were like everything I want you
beauty guru I should do this
and that's all that you just Boise overs
and just doing the [ __ ] makeup good
morning guys so today you know what this
one girl did this [ __ ] which I thought
was dope it was her doing her makeup but
she wasn't talking about her makeups
you're just talking about [ __ ] yeah
would be called it get ready with me
video oh is that what that is
I don't know she oh [ __ ] chat get ready
with me and it's where yeah you just
like do life updates and all of that and
those are way more fun to film because
you don't I mean like you know what to
do you're watching the video to learn
how to do the makeup you could just let
them [ __ ] off and talk about whatever it
does they want to talk about so yeah I
did that for a little while went nowhere
and you can do whatever you put your
mind to that's right yeah that's your
make a video it's too [ __ ] saturated
so yeah I did that and now I have my
YouTube channel and now I post whatever
I want
that's good though I mean I feel like
when you put yourself into a corner it
also like stifles your creativity you
know so like like when I saw you do the
ASMR stuff else I do this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] weird that's tight good is it
Mars is such a unique space and your are
you doing that [ __ ] where you talk real
quiet okay give us give us a real sample
real quick by the way this is gonna be
in probably some kind of weird porn and
already I'm doing sleeping
that's just so wild to soothing what is
it about that [ __ ] I don't know what it
is about ASMR videos that I like so
[ __ ] much it's literally well what's
crazy is Riley for example literally
hates he hates it like if I'm listening
to one or like I'll watch videos cuz I
try to get ideas he's like well please
turn that off I like put your headphones
and it's the worst thing to him it like
there are the people that find it really
cringey and then the people that are
just like oh this is the best thing of
my entire life
yeah I fall in the category of it's the
best thing of mine I just broke your
chair perfect I'm just kidding you know
what I won't I really wanted to do so
there was another category of as more
stuff that I like it's cooking
wood no just start an ASMR Channel
I would but I [ __ ] talk too much no
David it would be so good like the
weirdest
you have such a good voice but I would
wait I will say like the best ASMR
videos are the people who have accents
and that was oddly very soothing hell
yeah dude dude I'm just saying you've
got the mics you've got the headphones I
might as well just do it just please
just one video just one maybe I'll just
have another podcast it's just called
[ __ ] it'll be a source and then what
I wanted to do just for fun and and I
say this as if I have a lot of [ __ ]
time on my hands which I don't but I
want to do well I just literally tell
people about all the [ __ ] weird
dreams that I had I have like 30,000
[ __ ] words genius that is genius a
podcast all about dreams just dreams and
I have such vivid dreams like I write
them down like I had the weird dude
there's a dream that um like just for
example this was like that one of the
creepiest dreams I've ever had so I I
had a dream I had a dream you ever had a
dream so I had a dream where I was at
this trucker diner right in the middle
of nowhere so if you kind of look at it
it's just that long paved road there's
just tumbleweeds just desert whatever
but
it's gloomy outside and the cars outside
are very like 1950s type of cars oh yeah
so when I walk into this diner
everything is super old-fashioned you
had like the karaoke machine that you
put the quarters in checkered floor
patterns and everything so it's very
retro yeah you walk in I walk in I sit
down and I see this waitress she's like
about to pull in her because she's so
Frankie cuz she has so many so many
people to serve and as she's trying to
serve everybody she has her kid in her
hand she's holding her kid oh my god and
so I'm like ma'am just relax and she's
taking my orders like just give me your
kid I'll watch your kid just do what you
have to do and don't worry I'm gonna be
right here yeah she goes thank you so
much she has a kid on my plane with the
kid whatever and then all of a sudden
you see this dude just busted through
the [ __ ] door he kicks the [ __ ]
door open he goes yeah where the [ __ ] is
my kid oh my god sir screaming at the
waitress she goes what the [ __ ] and then
he looks at me he goes what the [ __ ] are
you doing with my kid my god at this
point in the dream I'm like yo yo man
like I'm not I'm not with her or
anything we're not a couple like he's
working I just help I'm just helping her
out right he goes to get the [ __ ] away
from my kid so you want to take this
[ __ ] outside it's like and you know
everybody is just kind of staring sounds
like y'all relax we'll talk outside
so I go we'll talk outside we walk
outside I go out first stupid I walk out
first I turn around and right when I
turned around he ran unto my head and he
[ __ ] blast me right in my head boom
black out why this is in the dream I get
shot in my [ __ ] dream boom just
little I literally walk outside I turn
around I go hey [ __ ] boom blows my
[ __ ] brains oh my god and then what
happens after I my brain gets blown down
I wake up again
and I'm back in the same dining table
with the kid I'm playing with the kid
again I'm like what the [ __ ] is going on
and so I see the same scenario again and
I'm like there's a guy that's about to
walk through that door the guy walks
through the door at the whole spiel and
he goes hey let's take it outside
same thing everything's the same so it
was like deja vu but this time because I
know what he's gonna do I haven't walked
out first I had my own gun and I [ __ ]
oh my god boom I wake up it was so
[ __ ] creepy I woke up in like a cold
sweat because number one like I don't
want to kill somebody but I had to do
something because I knew he had a gun on
him Davis nice so weird dream huh that
is
crazy I have like a bunch of weird
dreams written down like because they're
so vivid and I think I get these weird
dreams because I have I am an insomniac
and so I take like melatonin and
melatonin is just gonna ask if you take
any supplements or anything because that
can like make your dream so much more
vivid that's insane dude night I've had
did I feel like some really morbid
dreams - like I've had more bad dreams -
but like that that's that that feels
like it's beyond basic dream
comprehension though because not only
did you die which typically you never
actually I was reading that [ __ ] but you
don't actually die like it's not very
common I've never been killed in a dream
ever well lucky you everybody's killing
my dreams my dreams son of a [ __ ] so
yeah you're one you're not supposed to
die in the fact that you then came back
to the same scenario and with awareness
of the previous thing that happens so
crazy to me it was [ __ ] odd man like
I've I always get creeped out by some of
these things because I always wonder
like what does that mean right have you
considered like look know is there like
a dream therapist that you could I would
like to talk to him about it like yeah
what does that mean but I'm also scared
to know what they don't say yeah better
as like I even remember a dream that I
had when I was a kid that [ __ ]
traumatized me a little bit because it
it was literally that's yeah if it has
anybody ever asked you some some [ __ ]
up [ __ ] like you know if your mom and
dad were hanging off a cliff oh my god
you say first yes right so I actually
had a dream about this you know yeah but
it wasn't that my my dad and my mom was
hanging off it was my mom was it was it
was just that classic like sunsets going
down it's red it's purple it's you you
know yellow the hole it's a beautiful
scenery and everything else like that
like the hill and I and that cliff it's
rocky but there's grass on top of it and
then all I remember was in the dream I
was holding my mom's hand like this and
then my mom was like crying and I'm a
kid too I'm a kid I can't remember what
age I was but I remembered this dream so
vivid because it felt real to me and I
woke up bawling because I remember I was
holding her and then my mom was just
screaming just let me go and I could do
it as a kid and I was just like Siri me
as a kid like no no no no and then
literally I'm holding her with
everything that I have is a little kid
and knowing that I can't hold up an
adult because I had that reality in my
yeah nice remember just balling and my
mom was just like screaming just let me
go let me go let me go because she's
gonna die and then like I just literally
saw her slip Oh
fall and I started screaming and I woke
up screaming and I was oh my gosh yeah I
I remember all these like weird [ __ ]
things dude see I've had like I've had a
dream similar to that and I've never
forgot it either I think I was like 12
or 13 years old and I grew up with just
my mom and in the dreams like that are
the worst when like they take place in
your home and like you know cuz
sometimes in dreams you're in a new
environment you know it's your home in
the dream but it doesn't look like your
home but this one I was out at the movie
theater that was like down the street
from where I used to live and my mom had
called me and she was like there's
somebody in the house I need you to come
home now I'm really scared and it was
one of those dreams where I could see
what was going on over there you know
what I mean almost a movie like it was
switching scenes and I could see like
this hooded figure with a knife and my
mom was like strapped into the chair and
they started texting me and they're like
if you don't get here soon I'm gonna
slit her throat literally just like let
her [ __ ] throat
and I was like oh my and like freaking
out and so I get home and right as I'm
coming home they cut her [ __ ] throat
open and that was how my dream ended Oh
like my last image was the blood [ __ ]
wrenching down it was like that stays
with you that's that was a decade ago
and I still remember it because it was
so traumatized it's not real - but I
remember it like it's nothing what's
that pumpkin that's a little kitty cat
look at you I'm allergic as [ __ ] to you
maybe she knows - I think she likes me
because she knows I'm allergic I know
what y'all doing y'all talking which I'm
talking about I'm just gonna rub against
this table real quick I just had voices
the cat's a [ __ ] okay yeah okay well
y'all just gonna do your own thing
almost this what is Mexican [ __ ] oh my
god she got long nails that feels good
[ __ ] scratched me behind my ears you
know my damn spot
I like how my [ __ ] cats a thug and
[ __ ] okay or like a gay thug pick me up
[ __ ] let me know how it feels oh there
you go there you go make me feel
comfortable that's right there you go
my name's pumpkin [ __ ] everybody
loves me
there you go Oh am I gonna hop down baby
okay what sir allergic boy I know you
don't like me but I love you anyways I
like animals a lot but dude I wish I
wasn't allergic to cats but I am no I
actually am too a little bit I don't
know how I would function if I was
living in a house with cats oh you just
gotta take a certain girl it could be
though would be though Allegra please
reach out to David have you ever woken
up with a cat in your face and then boom
your eyes look like two [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Laughter]
want to fix it fast want to turn those
[ __ ] eyes have been normalized well
guess what
xur tech deep will help fix your eye
needs or Allegra 36 count at CBS now
going for $25.99 Oh would you for real
get that [ __ ]
so what have you been up to did oh man
um well just like everybody else in LA I
want to be an actress oh that's right
really well maybe what made you want to
go into acting cuz acting the [ __ ]
[ __ ] god it's like yeah it's a thing so
I have been in I mean I feel like
everyone says this that's why I hate
saying it but I've loved acting since I
was a little girl oh I really have
though yeah and like I mean from as
young as I can remember I was telling my
mom that I wanted to be in movies and
yeah I loved it a lot and but we also
where I grew up and I know this sounds
janky but where I grew up because I grew
up in San Francisco but then I went into
like the suburbs and stuff middle school
like Pleasant Hill Carl yeah and so I
had wanted to go and be a part of the
plays and stuff but this was like a real
like suburban area where you had to
actually pay to play it was like you
paid 300 bucks to be a part of the
rehearsals and get casted and people
play and the whole production that was
just not something that we could afford
or do
and so I never really participated in
plays I would just write my own scripts
and write my own stories and oh what's
great I loved it and but there was just
no option to really you know put myself
out there so I've been into it for a
long time but I also had like no formal
training so fun crazy story I went on
Craigslist when I was like I think I was
16 or 17 years a safe very safe very
safe crazy
yeah super safe 15 16 easily I'm gonna
start our acting class today by grabbing
you in the post and taking off your
clothes and they'll never find you you
want to be a star don't you today you're
gonna be a puppet and I'm gonna stick it
in there
[ __ ] crazy look so weird has that
happened to you huh of course exactly
gay
did you learn a lot I was the puppet of
Kim Jong yeah hard time speaking at any
point no I felt like maybe there was
like something I just clenched real hard
I actually snapped that fools fingers
off I was like I'm done with this no I
don't want this anymore
like a nice hard [ __ ] I just [ __ ]
Kegel the [ __ ] so I was yeah so I went
on Craigslist okay this is actually it
sounds like it's gonna end in
sketchiness but it actually is really
cool no not encouraging people to go on
Craigslist and have the same experience
I found this woman I was looking for an
acting coach and on her page it was like
you know I used to run the lifestyle and
children division stars agency which is
a really popular agency in San Francisco
and so she's like you know I'm taking on
clients to do one-on-one coaching
monologue work all of that so yeah oh
cool this is this is a good start so I
traveled all the way to like South San
Francisco to go and meet with her and I
felt like I was like the next Britney
Spears or something when I went in there
because I did a monologue they're
probably very mediocre Lee what was the
monologue it was just some random one
that she sent me I don't even think it
was anything oh you didn't get the
choose no it was just like hey bring
this in and work on it for for when we
meet
and she goes oh my god you've got it
you've got the it factor and I was like
you think this wasn't a [ __ ] scam
that sounds like a [ __ ] way okay so
where it was it okay
in my mind I'm thinking the same thing
my mom's like you know oh my god darling
yeah like you got it you've got you've
got the look that we need for this
agency that I'm no longer with but
you've got the look yeah and so I was
like alright let's do this yeah and
literally she's like I'm gonna set you
up with the meeting with the president
of the agency she did oh right I got
signed to the agency that week oh [ __ ]
yeah and I had two agents literally like
that I still don't understand how that
all happened but I completely spoiled
that opportunity because I was in beauty
school at the time and didn't go on
really any of the I went on like a
Disney audition but the see Oh should
but they sent me out for an Asian role
pretty good sense you could be Asian
really uh-huh tsuya Sakaya I think was
her name do I do I look like my name
could be hot serious i kya
Han do this now but you look you could
be like Persian or [ __ ] Indian or
something for sure but then when they
said we're sending you out for a
Japanese role I was like I would I would
have just took it do it I would have
been like Audie got tho [ __ ] doing
let's [ __ ] do it
Broca's [ __ ] [ __ ] hajiman my stick
arigato gozaimasu
Sam what I saw it konichiwa boy touch my
sister
[Music]
everything I did I did I did I went I
went it but I mean that was like they
sent me on so many different things and
I never really did any of them so I was
younger dude like if it came for a big
opportunity like that if I didn't want
to be an act like look this is this role
is for a ripped black 26 year old male I
was like got it mother perfect I'm ready
let's do it boy could you stop hamming
it up black people don't sound like that
is how we gonna do it you know they're
like
okay that's what we're going for this
time yeah yeah so so I I ended up
getting dropped from them when I moved
away rightfully so but now I'm with UTA
which is a great agency if you guys
don't know it's really when you get
signed to you kidding me um it's been
over you know okay yeah so Hello Kitty
did you hear I know she's like somebody
play with me it's like come on
[ __ ]
yo man stupid white Kurtis I'm gonna get
back is the podcast gonna hear that too
it doesn't matter this is on me I just
want to know are they gonna hear it
maybe but that was a sound of a kitty
cat [ __ ] yeah so so yeah I've
been with them for over a year and I've
gone through one pilot season so far and
I've had one it's it's hard
I've had one call back and it was for a
really good it was for good TV shows
four stars it was for a lead but acting
is like one of those things that you
could pursue for 15 years and just start
massive super green you're very young
yeah exactly
like for me to like in acting I like I
don't really want to be honest with you
I don't really want to be an actor like
I'm just I'm just doing it just because
I can you know so I don't really have
what a lucky guy I only have like a
hardcore passion for it but I do like
film so that's the difference it's like
I like film and if people said do what
you want to be an actor that's hard for
me to say it's hard for me to say like
acting is my passion because it's not
it's not in the forefront it's
definitely not in the form of my agents
know that they know it's not in the
forefront I said I know roles that I
like I know roles that I want to do and
those that are the roles that I want to
kill and like when I did my first pilot
season run I had like seven or eight
callbacks and so I know the roles that
I'm good at you know
that's amazing so good you know any
people oh my god that's so good I see
like I feel like if we when you don't
pressure on yourself and you just know
what what you're gonna do like there's
no so let me tell you about this
audition that I got that I knew for a
fact I wasn't gonna get right and this
should make me laugh right and it was
for this [ __ ] werewolf show I forgot
what the [ __ ] it was but the role well
and this is by the way I was 275 275
pounds heavyset acne and the role was
for like this guy well for like a 16
year old kid right that's a wolf they're
supposed to be like this
symbol of the show and I looked at this
script and I was like are you [ __ ]
with me I did it anyways you know my
agent was like dude they just need to
see your face of what for what am i the
werewolf that retired like it he just
didn't give a [ __ ] about his life like
what would what am I doing this for and
I'm literally trying to go through the
scene without laughing because like the
the scene was a very emotional thing
between me and my love interests what
we're talking about why I can't be with
her why she doesn't want to be with me
is because I killed one of her other
like werewolf homies or so she got you
right so it's like you know we got it
you know we still love each other I like
listening to myself like David you are
not going to get destroyed absolutely
not
it's not even for an Asian guy and it's
definitely you're definitely not sexy
dude like this is not your role like I'm
that goofy dude so there were roles like
where I I just didn't feel like he was
Bob I still did it anyways but you know
the stuff that I did get callbacks for
it was stuff that was right up my alley
it was copy it was it was comedic roles
it was goofy it was fun yeah and I I
enjoyed it yeah you know the stuff that
the hard part about being an actor in my
personal opinion is like the reason why
I say I'm not a great actor and I'm not
going to be is because I don't like
playing roles that I don't want to play
no and and that's totally fine and I
think that's so good though that you're
aware of that and also like being a
great actor it does involve so much work
it has to become well there's this part
where you you know you you're you're not
playing a character you are the
character right and that's right that's
what everybody says but for me what I do
is I read the script I hate it I'm like
no I'm rewriting this I'm rewriting this
because I don't like it because I'm a
creative director yeah you have direct
earnest and you like directorial
attitude to write and like my taste of
like like for real for real acting is
when I made that film I got into
Sundance and that stuff that I did -
just crazy yeah you know and that's
that's the experience that I have right
so I experienced with film where I got
to control with my friends this this
area the scenario so I want to do things
the way I want to do which you do have
that flex and freedom when you audition
right yeah so you do it within your own
taste and however you interpret this
character right but they're like in all
honesty like when I read these like
multicam sitcoms I [ __ ] hate it like
yes these lines are so [ __ ] tell the
cam is so dated now in fact
there are still TV shows that are trying
to do multicam makes no sense and I look
at it I'm like this [ __ ] is gonna
[ __ ] tank yeah and even if so a lot
of you guys who don't go in acting that
don't know this like let's say a show
goes on right let's say you went through
you went through your first audition you
go through your callback guess what you
got another callback after that then
you're gonna be put up against somebody
else and then you have to go through
that callback and the only reason why
you're allowed to come in is because
they actually had somebody in mind for
that we're all already but they said no
so you're actually the backup to the
backup and then you at the fight for
this rule then you go into testing
unless that you get into testing you
pass testing right you book the [ __ ]
wall you shoot the [ __ ] pilot right
two episodes go and guess what the show
gets canned or or this show gets picked
up and they decide to recast yeah
there's a lot of things that happen
right so like that percentage of you
actually getting on it I'm not doing
this to discourage people what I'm
saying is that when you say you want to
be an actor just know what you're gonna
get into it takes a long time it's a
[ __ ] process there's literally
hundreds of thousands of people that are
going for that one [ __ ] rule right
and so you have to figure out do I have
something that special or do I have the
dedication to actually figure out that
yo even if I don't get to this point
well I still be happy doing this yeah
and that's the hard part exactly a lot
of my friends are going through that
right now where they're like dude I've
been doing this for like six seven years
and I haven't gotten [ __ ] like I've
gotten a couple of like supporting roles
or whatever but I'm still not there well
that's the risk that you take when you
go into acting exactly do you love it
enough where even if nothing happens you
will look back and say I loved every
second of it that's the heart that's the
hard part
and I also think that especially right
now there are so many influencers who
are trying to get into acting too and
it's creating a really I guess crappy
stigma for anybody who actually cares
about acting that happens to be an
influencer as well which is the category
that I'm in like by no means did I go to
NYU's you know acting program and on
that level but I do genuinely have a
passion for it and so you've got the
people who go into it with absolutely no
experience no and don't care to have any
experience but yet want to be the next
Meryl Streep and it's like and so I feel
I don't know I guess I just feel like
it's kind of making it a different
experience and people are viewing it
but differently and so the question of
like will you look back and say that you
loved it a lot of these people aren't
even going into it because they love it
they just want it for a completely
different reason like fame or whatever
yeah so I don't know I I guess if
there's any advice and just in case if
there is any of you guys who want to get
into acting just if you can write your
own thing just like David did like write
your own script and create your own
project because at the end of the day
like you don't want to spend your whole
life reliance on YouTube
I don't do sketches but I'm actually
working on two pilots right now oh
really
yeah for the first time ever because I I
really did get to a point where I was
like I mean and it's only been a year
for me but I'm like I don't want to wait
forever to get booked for something like
I want to write something and I will
star in my own thing that I've written
so I mean but I don't have no idea if
it's gonna be successful or not but I'm
gonna try my very best and I'll at least
feel like I get to work cuz it's not
even about it being on CW or I just want
to work I just want to act I just press
it you know so if I can write my own
thing and and only a hundred people see
it I honestly don't give a [ __ ] that
sounds perfect to me like yeah I just
want to do it and I think that's so
important I think that's a very healthy
attitude to have because like
auditioning is hard man like I keep
telling people man like people go well
just going in and you're reading these
lines that's like well you know you
don't you can't even stand getting
rejected by one job interview try doing
[ __ ] twelve in a week and then having
people say no to you for three months
straight yes right and then you see
other people who you think are hot
garbage get a role in the world I could
have killed that lost them [ __ ] son
of a [ __ ] I could be buff I could do
that I could have sex
I'm sex I could be gay I am a gay I'm a
gay I can do it all I could do it how
you do now I could do it [ __ ] right
now he was funny like there was an
audition that I was gonna get that I
really wanted but my my manager I
decided not to do it for me he goes
because like the the role was for
somebody who was like
flamboyantly gay house like bright
[ __ ] kill that my god it was like you
sure you ready for that for your first
road that's gonna be the first thing
that people remember each other I don't
give a [ __ ] you know but I guess like in
it what his thing was like he goes do
you kill it like it'd be dope yeah yeah
but he goes as your first role like I
like people to see you in more like a
mask in light because it does the the
thing that you first come out and that
is how people are gonna then yeah look
at you and they're gonna put categorize
you as annoying as that can be so it's
like if you do access accept something
like that then you might get piggy holed
into something dude I really wonder -
this - one of my friends asked me goes
yo so there's a role that they want you
in like it's like you're supposed to be
a fluffy asian dude but you have a gay
scene like a gay sex scene with somebody
I'm like I'm not at that point yet
because I would giggle I would giggle
I'd be giggling through the whole
thing's like dude this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] crazy dude
I got a I'm kissing the dude and I'm
grabbing his ass cheeks I'd be laughing
throughout the whole thing I'd be
[ __ ] laughing actor you know yeah I
had to somehow get into that role and
not laugh that there's a [ __ ] dick
next to me yes you know yeah you would
have to completely think of you'd have
to imagine it cuz I don't think like as
long beyond its like disgust me per se
but it would make me laugh you'd be like
so hard as a peanut there's somebody
else's penis I mean they're snail
trailer my son of a [ __ ] if this I call
it the snail trail where they just drag
that dick right across you yeah the guy
just just drag his big across your
forehead and all the way dispenser all
the way down with a [ __ ] so don't do
the smell show thing maybe I'm not ready
for yet let me let me snail trail you
what are you doing beforehand just
[ __ ] and then you stop at the belly
button you circle that around that's
right because you have to put into the
charging port so you guys this is why he
should have been the [ __ ] werewolf I
told you dude even in a easy dude have
you seen a fat werewolf they're just as
scary
not they're scarier yeah who's not
scared of a [ __ ] grizzly bear huh
think about that [ __ ] dude oh they
turned into a grizzly but it would have
made so much more sense din I'm just
over there I swear I love you Jennifer I
love you more than [ __ ] pot of honey I
swear to god oh my god is so good where
did you get that [ __ ] pot of honey
sir wait you guys don't just have pots
of honey okay do you guys not see bears
ever so I should I put this away or do
you guys would you see this Christopher
Robin movie no dude makes me cry like a
[ __ ]
well which one because I feel like they
came out with two there was two of them
so there's one that's more realistic but
this is the CG CG did you see Jen they
don't have the CD but I had this one has
the one that I saw is called Christopher
Robin and it has the CG Winnie the Pooh
Yee or yeah and it looks very it looks
like stuffed animal [ __ ] good oh my
god I know I when I saw it it was coming
out cuz it's about because they have the
one where it's how he became and then
this is when he the one's real life and
the one's not I can't remember what the
other one is the other one is the actual
story about the author
okay so it's like like during the time
like World War two or some [ __ ] like
that right so that the the real story is
kind of loosely based off that but it
has the whole the CG fake characters but
man I'll tell you this though that [ __ ]
made me cry like a [ __ ]
I've been bad sensitive lately do I
think I'm lactating you might be PMS you
know I'm telling you like I pick up some
tampons and let's do it plug up my
butthole and feed me I'm telling you man
that Christopher Robin movie the reason
why I like it so much I say the [ __ ] on
JK news and people might be sick of it
but [ __ ] you this is my podcast watch
that it's on Netflix okay I'll watch it
tonight then so it's just it really goes
back to something that I feel like as an
adult you struggle with the lot which is
um people tell you that you have to grow
up so you have to be a certain way and
that's what that film really highlights
it so you kind of like forgo what makes
you happy because you feel like you
to be an adult right and that [ __ ] is
stuff that I struggle with my whole life
you know so when I reach a certain age
you shouldn't talk that way anymore and
I just because I'm an [ __ ] I'm like
the more you say that the more I'm gonna
be the way yeah like don't curse I'm
gonna curse so [ __ ] much [ __ ] just
because you said that [ __ ] yeah yeah but
that I loved it and it just [ __ ] made
me ball up dude and there's so much like
people don't even know Winnie the Pooh
has life lessons like a mother oh are
you kidding me
you should still watch old school Winnie
the Pooh episodes and there's still life
lessons happening there's so much wisdom
there's so many one like dude this is
one-liner like well I just wanted to go
into the scene and bitch-slap
Christopher Robin so hard he goes like
poo I haven't thought about you in 30
years and the poo goes oh I thought
about you every day I'm telling you man
that she gets me dude I'm like the first
thing I wanted to go into the screen and
I wanted to [ __ ] back my middle finger
all the way back and shove it in his
face you [ __ ]
you thought about him every day okay
that's gonna make me cry
because I'm gonna be messed up Winnie
the Pooh was so genuine about his love
and he was just waiting for Christopher
Robin to come back and he hadn't seemed
in 30 years 30 years okay I'm gonna
watch it [ __ ] ass [ __ ] you know
well text you the second I finish it you
sure I'll try if my phone's not [ __ ]
broken from water damage until all the
stuff is subtle and I feel like it made
me cry a lot just because I related it
yeah they did to it so much one also
like we grew up with it so oh dude
that's I don't even know Winnie the Pooh
was Disney oh you did I didn't because
I'm not a huge Disney fan unless it's
like 2d [ __ ] so like a language like
that but we need the poos like my
favorite thing like I as an adult I
still [ __ ] with Wade the poo heavy
Winnie the Pooh is my 5 a.m. cartoon
when I was like getting ready to go to
school in the morning to do my thing
your you know Christopher Robin I
[ __ ] look [ __ ] yeah okay I love that
guy Oh have you seen um have you seen a
star is born stars born oh I did in with
Bradley Cooper's yeah
Bradley Cooper's and Lady Gaga's yeah I
heard that [ __ ] is [ __ ] dope oh my
god let me tell you okay I'm friends
with people who consider themselves to
be like movie buffs and when I told them
about a star is born you know you hear
Bradley Cooper you've never really seen
him in a genuinely serious role yeah
maybe one or two but for the most part
you think of hangover and so then you
hear Lady gaga and you're like okay
what's actually going on here it's also
the third remake of a classic Hollywood
film third or fourth or something it's a
lot I went into it with no actually
didn't want to see the movie cuz
everybody was talking about it it made
me not want to see it I was like come on
like like shut the [ __ ] up yeah it's
probably not that good I like five
minutes in I was like hooked and then
that movie is emotional really yes it is
like I continued to cry when I left like
I was in my car I put on the soundtrack
and I continued me and my best friend
just sat in the car for like five
minutes and cry it is so emotional but
it is so good is it like when you watch
like America's Got Talent and they have
like a blind Chinese kid and then he
starts singing like Whitney Houston
really yeah that show does that [ __ ] to
you on purpose
oh yeah one thousand alike anybody here
who has had any traumatic experiences
but is also very talented please come to
the front we are going to highlight the
the sad moments of your life and you
know make make you famous yeah they just
literally find like the most sad people
that has the the highest level of talent
on earth and then right when they do it
it's like the most beautiful thing
you've ever [ __ ] seen dude
little Wang pal from [ __ ] bombs out
China right has three fingers no but
three shakers no but one eye half a year
lobe and 16 a little wang tao comes up
he goes hello I want to sing for
everybody and then Simon Cowell's over
there life hmm
well go ahead let's hear what you
brought let's hear what [ __ ] got you
[ __ ] slant-eyed [ __ ] I think I said
that [ __ ] just seems like some emotional
soul songs yeah and then I'll send the
whole trouble does one eyebrow raise
it's all he does he does nothing but
mm-hmm and then Nicole Scherzinger is
[ __ ] crying she's crying so much
and then she's hitting Simon for being
an [ __ ] Oh every time did and then
Simon is the first person speaking he
goes that was amazing
he goes no he usually will pause and
they'll all look at him and then he goes
I've got to say I've got to say you're
going to they always get me on that [ __ ]
dude I remember do I I do definitely
tear up when I see like an amazing
talent oh yeah oh my gosh well and all
you know the part that makes me cry
though is not the talent it's it's all
of its like the ambience of the audience
reacting bad yeah it's all of it and
that's the part that makes me cry cuz
I'm like I imagine what it must feel
like for them to go on the stage scared
shitless and just have everyone just
think you're just incredible and you're
like oh my God my life is changing
that's the part that always makes me cry
but there's also the other side where
there's people who have that same story
but they're completely not talented and
they just use it for laughs and I also
love that and you know I used to think
that I'm pretty sure it's staged to the
point where they find these human beings
but these human beings actually do exist
so when I was out in Buffalo New York
there's a [ __ ] true story by the way
I was out in Buffalo New York and I'm
supposed to judge a talent show contest
right oh cool like I like this you know
there's some talented Asian kids out
there so I'd love to do this [ __ ] so
buffing your call this [ __ ] were there
and they're doing a talent show this is
kid Chinese kid thick accent and he did
a great performance like the guy was a
stand
coming [ __ ] made me laughs yes well
did this set where he had a guitar and
he's saying Lady Gaga's lalala lady but
he had a thick Chinese accent so it came
as tears laughing I'm like hitting
everybody next to me like yo this guy's
[ __ ] fun yeah so we go back and then
we're tallying up the points I get this
for like tens all across the yeah and
everybody else looks at me and they go
you're giving him tenth I'm like dude
that guy was [ __ ] hilarious was David
he was serious oh I was in the front row
laughing and pointing at him everybody
but he was [ __ ] serious and I was
giving it I laughed
directly into the windows of his school
I have never been so mortified in my
life he's like seeing his heart out oh
my god
crying oh my god no part of you for a
moment thought he was serious I didn't
think he was serious at all ooh rah rah
baby gah gah gah Wow
I was like dude this guy's a mean he's
[ __ ] Bernie oh my god one of the
worst things I've ever done but I say
this to also dimension how [ __ ]
delusional he is he came up to me after
the show right and he goes hey man I
just wanted to let you know that I'm
also seeing I heard you're single and
you're just as good as me so maybe we
could get on a track together I wanted
to choke him out [ __ ] dare you you're
hilarious
but don't you ever say that [ __ ] to me
again but that's how like some people
just live in ask what happened after no
he doesn't he does he's not faced and
also like no part of him even seem to be
fazed at the fact that you were laughing
and I'm not even lying to you I started
talking to him you know because you know
they want to have conversations because
they see the route that I went not the
traditional college route they want to
do it too he goes he goes to be honest
with you in the next year I'm going to
quit college I'm going to quit
everything I'm like don't do that stay
stay
because of your like no you keep that
degree all right you're an engineer
engineer don't you [ __ ] dare because
you're gonna end up poor so you're like
no no no you got to save Monica
Boulevard right now sing the same song
what are the worst things I've ever was
to my life dude but I'm pretty sure even
for you like the like a lot of people
probably ask you for advice like in
deems aside from the guys trying to [ __ ]
you [ __ ] what do you mean by that what
guys trying to slide into my DMS and be
super creepy and send me a thank you
happens to me sometimes I'm pretty sure
happens to you
yes yes how do you know a [ __ ] deal
with that [ __ ] dude like it's like you
know why because here's the thing I read
these comments right and what I want to
say to these dudes are what the [ __ ] do
you think was gonna happen I owe one I
like when you see this yo what's up
beautiful yo let me tell you something
I'm the one day could treat you right
yeah holla back at me one love hashtag
let me tell you something you [ __ ]
fuzzy haired [ __ ] nobody gives a [ __ ]
about you and what the [ __ ] did you
think was gonna happen to ban it yes
you know I so I have so many different
ways that I've approached this
throughout my Instagram career it is a
career to be honest but yeah I don't
know Instagram yeah uh so it depends on
how I'm feeling that day because
sometimes I mean I've gotten all types
of different games I've got the guy
who's just like I want to take you to
you know my high school dance and I'm
like oh really I don't even like going
to like I'd even like weed in my nose
like I would need to see my instance
stories I've seen you dance
so you see exactly have you seen the way
I do because yeah I'm pretty good yeah
you really don't want me at your dances
oh so you've got those who are just like
okay
that's sweet but then you've got the guy
who's like you want this dick girl and
it's like a nude and then another nude
of him from a different angle and then
like a new nude that maybe he took a few
hours ago and the other ones are like I
don't even know there's all different
types but when guys specifically asked
me for nudes and they're like show me
like you know show me your tits or
whatever I just literally will either
send them a really ugly picture that I
find on Google and like like cuz because
the thing is the way that Instagram
works now is I have to have my own form
of trolling so now Instagram will say
you know maybe sensitive content so
they'll blur out the picture so to them
they're like oh my god she responded she
sent me a picture and then they either
see like me flipping them off or they
see like my dog's wiener or like
whatever you know and then it's either
they never get mad they'll either say
like oh my god I didn't think you're
gonna respond I'm so sorry for saying
that to you or they go like oh so funny
and you [ __ ] yeah it also man it's so
odd have you ever gotten a DM from a
really cute guy that were you like oh
[ __ ] oh my god Dawg you're like wait
hold on a second I know the other ones a
creep you are too but at least you cute
what's ugly they're never though it's
always the guy where you're like you had
no business sending this DM you had no
business sending me DM saying like you
know I can treat you right like I'm the
reason there hasn't been a man in your
life I'm like you need to relax if
you're saying that definitely you're not
you're not the reason my friend thinking
like you [ __ ] dweeb and there's
nothing that pisses me off more because
I am like I wouldn't say I'm like a
hardcore feminist but I definitely am
like it's [ __ ] 2019 woman Rock like
you know let's all empower each other
and so when a guy comes in and they're
like you know you need a man dad I'm
like I actually don't need a man at all
so please just shut the [ __ ] do you know
what I [ __ ] do all right
I will [ __ ] [ __ ] I swear to God I
will deadlift your dick to another
universe I will snap that [ __ ] [ __ ]
Titan
top and I'll squeeze now bend that bar
drop dude [ __ ] all that blood will
come on out
[ __ ] send that [ __ ] to orbit get the
[ __ ] out of here can I just anytime I
get creepy DS I'm just gonna send them
to you and you have to come up with a
good rose no doubt I was like let me
tell you something you [ __ ] foreskin
face [ __ ] I will slice you up dude if
you ever even come near me I will slice
you to a [ __ ] oblivion daddy's good
you forced I wish I was a bad [ __ ] dude
if I was a bad [ __ ] first of all I
probably hope but second of all I'd be a
selective home and third of all do it
when I reject somebody I will crush
their [ __ ] spirit day yes I will make
sure you were great you were ever born
the best DM I ever got was from like no
joke ok this person basically goes like
hey baby girl like I love following you
on Instagram you're so bad that it I can
click on this person's profile he's 11
oh he is 11 and he's smoked you I can
even be mad because it was just like him
in the mirror like grew up in the
suburbs like in his look nice little
house and he's like I really 10 I would
heal yeah I would find his last name
find him on Facebook cuz he definitely
has a Facebook for sure and I was saying
to his parents I know that's a good idea
I could never find my friend Gina does
that so she finds like these little kids
that [ __ ] first of all like demean
women oh they say whatever they they're
12 13 years old they send to their
parents and their [ __ ] parents what
there because they these parents don't
know how these kids talk to women yeah
yeah I mean first of all number one like
I'm really close to my mom like I I talk
to my mom like almost every day yeah so
I grew up with that really tight
relationship so you know a lot of the
stuff that I feel like even when I was
younger when you know a lot of the guy
friends about yo y'all [ __ ] them I
always felt a little weird about it yeah
so you know this is like during a time
when I'm super young I just want to be a
part of the group so you know I would be
involved with that type of [ __ ] I'm not
saying that when I'm in in Miami and I
see a fat ass I'm like God
of course I'm still a dude but I know
would I ever say that to a woman like
absolutely not right in my mind I'm like
they're just there am I not supposed to
look what am I supposed to do but I
cover my face bags because they say [ __ ]
like this like you don't know what I do
with that
exactly you wouldn't know what yeah
right I would snap your dick I would
break it I would Kegel they I say mess
up things were like if it were up to me
like I would literally chop off their
Weiner and then like peel off the skin
and then cut it into little sausage
pieces and feed it to them yeah you you
good without me I think you're good okay
it's like the weirdest thing that I
thought maybe I'm a BLT fry it maybe
there's some ice cream on top of it yeah
why the [ __ ] not I'm getting hairy
what the [ __ ] won't you just say yeah I
don't know man like these kids are kind
of weird but I it's not even just this
generation the guys have been doing it
for a minute
yeah for a long time they're just
emulating like some of these scumbags
that they see like online is [ __ ] and
these dudes - they had like this weird
habit of telling people yo I smashed
this chick you know this girl that girl
and it's like yell bro first of all I'm
your friend and I know you got rejected
38 times before you found the one drunk
ugly [ __ ] that would [ __ ] oh oh my god
right truth yes so it's not like you're
this [ __ ] suave dude that's just
[ __ ] taking down girls
you're that [ __ ] creep that got
rejected X amount of times and then
finally somebody was dumb enough to say
yes so don't and you but that's not how
they tell the story
no no no they make it seem like they are
Rico suave and they just finished their
way because they're so charming and
whatever I did whatever yeah yeah 1,000%
it's very cringy and I have done my best
and I knew so many guys like that like
especially when I lived back in the bay
and now I just like make it a point to
avoid anybody like the play because you
can sense it right away like based off
the way that they which is so
unfortunate that I'm saying that because
then somebody might say the same thing
about me but you can tell by the post
that they put on Instagram or like how
can dare you Jasmine [ __ ] fast fat
ass picture
I can't even say cuz so fat fast dude
there there are times to like because I
follow my friends a lot you know I don't
follow a lot of like women I think I
feel like because it's so abundant on
Instagram you kind of get desensitized
to everything right
totally yeah and so like it's just like
I get it like I'm not say number one
like when I see her pictures I'm like
that's a nice ass she has a very nice
derriere oh thank you and I'm going to
appreciate cuz I'm an ass man
but then it gets to that point to where
like people are like whoa have you seen
this girl this girl I'm like not really
I don't really know her right at this
point and if you haven't lived in LA
there's a lot of it's just an abundance
yeah so you do really do get
desensitized yeah after a while but
sometimes like I flipped on my first
night why you fallen is Mary okay with
you following this girl I was like yeah
you know I mean this is [ __ ] photo
that I wanted to recreate so bad when I
was away but I didn't do it was like you
on the beach in your ass you're talking
about told me you were going to it all
so excited in your life recreate one of
my pictures like I kind of want to gain
eighty pounds again just so I could do
because it's funnier when I'm bigger I
mean cuz like if I cuz if I get buff and
I do it then it's just like oh what are
you trying to show off your muscles
being like the fatter guy doing it may
need laughs oh my god
when you would put okay there are so
many times that I would be in a public
location scrolling through my phone
picture of you on the wall with your ass
crack out what you open if you write
comments like dude I was with my family
I just write back
you took the [ __ ] risk on you get
that follow button alright that's that's
the risk you literally I but for me it
was so funny cuz I was like smiling
while zooming in and then realizing like
oh [ __ ] I'm at a grocery so people are
so funny too because every time I do
that I lose like a thousand guys really
but then I'll gain like 2,000 oh yeah so
it's like you [ __ ]
homophobic [ __ ] like weird on
social media I didn't realize that like
people actually were touchy about that
stuff until I think I'd posted
I had post about Thanksgiving and how I
don't like I don't really celebrate our
acknowledge it because it's a pretty
[ __ ] terrible day
don't worry rung I'll eat the food like
I'm not like against it but I don't post
like I'm so thankful for my family
I just don't yeah and I post about why
and and so many people were so offended
they were just like why would you turn
it into this and that I'm like well
literally like people got slaughtered
that day so you know but people were so
offended and people started following me
and then I'd like had posted from
politics ones I'd post about gay rights
once and people you really see like just
how much that can offend or affect
people and it's so interesting because
to me regardless I'm always like okay
that's your opinion
yeah of anything you know if I may not
agree with it and you might be a [ __ ]
terrible person for it but I'm not gonna
like destroy your character but you
don't like things giving Jess
[ __ ] you ain't never been to my
Thanksgiving I'll cook
I couldn't mother [ __ ] bottle release
I'm Kramer I was born on the Korean so
eat the food no I'll go I don't eat let
me take some [ __ ] you like
Thanksgiving all right if you eating a
[ __ ] turkey that means you like
thanks even you celebrating that [ __ ]
Turkey huh you ain't had my turkey
though much thank you [ __ ] me good my
[ __ ] turkeys potatoes and gravy and
stuffing okay and that's how it gets all
to the booty huh how why why don't you I
genuinely think turkey is just [ __ ] your
Mexican eyes at me do you understand
memory can damn it I don't give a [ __ ]
what you are alright my [ __ ] Puerto
Rican [ __ ] you understand me
what's your turkey like David that's
important Rican food right now blackness
blast on the [ __ ] rope of your hair I
don't give a [ __ ] that [ __ ] did anyways
my turkey I actually spatchcock it and
then I'd assembly what does that even
mean
spatchcock well I know chef what the
[ __ ] all the time I'm telling you
subscribe so you so special hug swear
you flat flatten it out so what ain't so
I either spatchcock cook it right
and then I dry brine it versus doing a
wet brine and then so when you
spatchcock it it actually Browns the
whole thing completely evenly cuz you
spread the whole turkey out right and it
allows it to cook even better or i
disremember everything and then i'm so
sorry but that's what it is dismembered
yes I slaughter it I murder it I murder
that I should i'll Suvi them in a water
bath right okay so I cook it to the
right temperature and then at the end I
[ __ ] deep-fry that [ __ ] so it's
golden and crispy so it's more like pork
like okay that's different
it's [ __ ] good my turkeys [ __ ]
I've just only ever had roasted turkey
and it's just always been dry and not
flavorful yeah I mean if you're deep
frying it dude do my thang is [ __ ] it's
hella good dude my god I'm not an
amazing cook but then I do cook certain
things that I enjoy and those things I
do really well so okay I say like
amazing cook is somebody who could make
anything out of everything yeah so me
I'm more like I know the specific thing
that I've worked so many times over that
I know it's gonna be good can I ask you
a question then yeah you know chef to
chef I just started using my crock-pot
I'm just saying I've made three recipes
in my crock-pot so far and I'm [ __ ]
killing it uh as an amateur
what would you cuz okay so I you just
kind of answered my question because
I've been curious when someone says like
oh they're a terrible cook did it it's
like okay are they are terrible cook
because they don't know how to follow
directions from a recipe or as are they
a terrible cook because they don't know
how to throw things together in a pot
and make something people usually
qualify themselves as a bad cook because
you can follow instructions but there's
no just a lot of variables to it right
okay and so cooking becomes very
daunting because you don't understand
the foundations and the basics of what
cooking is cooking is alchemy you take a
product and you create something into
something else
it's [ __ ] magic is sorcery to me okay
and so the best way to start how to be a
really good cook to be honest with you
is number one you have to eat good food
and then you have to learn how to try to
cook it that's I mean is as basic as it
gets I know it sounds really simple but
people get stuck because they go okay so
we want you to heat the skill to medium
I do what the Bacchus medium right oh
okay that makes me stop
see season it to taste it's stuck on
these terms right okay that makes so
much more sense
yeah and or they say die something and
they go what's dicing how big is a dice
when I mince it how much do I mention am
I supposed to be supposed to be this big
how much is a table tablespoon like so
people get stuck on these small games
and so what would you kind of forget to
is that number one you're gonna eat it
you're gonna [ __ ] it out if you like the
way it tastes then it's good for you
yeah right right right that's that's how
most things start some people just don't
have a palate for great food that a lot
of people can enjoy right and that's
just either it hasn't been developed or
you just don't have a talent for it and
that's okay but if you understand basics
like basics basic knife cutting basic
terminology and understand that most
ingredients are the same to make some
type of dish you'll be pretty much okay
yeah see cuz I I'm 24 now and I'm just
I'm telling you like this week I'm
getting into cooking I don't know where
this newfound passion came from but I've
hated cooking for as long as I could
remember like it's just not something
really if it was like hello fresh or
like those things were there already
positive you oh my god it's great and
and I think that that kind of ignited it
where I was like oh I kind of get this
because the directions are right there
everything's portioned out it's a very
good introduction again not sponsored
but those types of companies are good
introductions for that but then I just
like I start going I've started using a
crock-pot and I'm starting to see a diet
okay great way to start oh my god so
that's what I've been doing so the last
few days I made like yesterday made
teriyaki chicken and I was so shocked
that it actually came out good and so
now I'm just like on this high of
cooking see you could do teriyaki
chicken just with the basic stuff and
the reason why I like crock pots but
sometimes I don't like it because people
use a tool as a crutch so you're not
you're you're cooking but you're not
really learning how to cook so if you
start with the foundation you start
understanding ingredients then you start
becoming like this this scientist you
get to try your own stuff out right yeah
so start with like like basic stuff like
like how to cook a steak that's
something very basic how to cook an egg
properly you start with those techniques
it teaches you how to manage heat well
it teaches you how to season things
properly because if even people people
say this all the times like all the
times [ __ ]
people say this so people say this all
the time if you if
if you know how to cook an egg properly
any type of way then you're a pretty
good chef oh really
yeah so if you could scramble an egg
properly if you could do it over easy
over medium hard boiled egg however many
ways I can only scramble and do
hard-boiled yeah but you'd be surprised
people can't even scramble eggs really
really yeah it's like people don't know
how to do that very good at scrambling
eggs well that's what I'm saying not a
lot when I was in where is it called I
went to some place to go see the snow
mammoth mammoth and I there was like a
bunch of us I was the head of scrambled
eggs they wanted me
that is [ __ ] amazing I'm not saying
that I'm the best but use butter on the
best what did I have
I mean I would have preferred to use
butter but I'm pretty sure I used oil oh
so you didn't have the butter this one
you [ __ ] up this and you can always
add milk to make them more fluffy you
don't need milk though [ __ ] you don't
need it but it'll make it more fun no we
won't
it won't not really all you got to
really do is its temperature control
that [ __ ] so a lot of lot of times when
people scramble eggs they do it at too
high of a heat and so it becomes really
hard and rubbery which people are used
to that stuff it's kind of like that
that's like Denny's and it's like farmer
style right but if you if you put like a
knob of butter put some knob of butter
before the pan - and enduring and then
you saw towards the end but I do a whole
thing of butter just a knob like oh when
you said I wouldn't use a knob I for
some reason because the whole stick of
butter drink it's like it's like you to
see what happens if you don't pass out
from an excess amount of fat then puke
it up put it back in there you go
and then you make pink pancakes pancakes
what is going on you are [ __ ] up my
English right now you pour like a [ __ ]
because I stutter a lot and my stutter
pushes on to other people ho no I'm
serious I think that's what it is I know
I did hear Puerto Rican yeah
I just heard Garcia I was like that's
Mexican if I've ever heard of it
yeah I'm Puerto Rican Salvadorian and
Italian okay my bag uses all the sexy
booby and Cuban and you should have
Miami are you sure yeah I know I should
be in Miami but I'm not I feel like
every time I hear it girls like Peruvian
Colombian I like Caribbean I'm just like
[Laughter]
I know I haven't actually spent like a
sufficient moment of time in Miami to
see all of the beautiful woman but
everybody anytime I talk to people
they're just like oh my god a woman in
Miami or because it's a huge tourist
place right and it's not only are the
women really beautiful the dudes are
buff is fun I know this ride it out yeah
a woman or two though look like a
blobfish they're like I don't feel
self-conscious about the way I look ever
yeah Miami I [ __ ] do all these dudes
are just like what's going on
why is the pregnant woman buff why is a
child but everybody's buffing it is just
like shooting up alright server yeah
just in a second yeah yeah there people
are I guess because it's it's known for
that type of vibe people like either
work out a lot before they get there but
they get their body tight oh yeah you go
there and I'm out there looking like a
Geisha dude that is true people are
always like I'm gonna be me I mean a few
weeks I gotta get my body right gotta
get my body right that's so true it's
hard being buff though dude like I've
lost this amount of weight but I know
what it takes to be buff and I don't
think I want to do it it's intense
I don't want to do it yeah I keep
finding out what they took like gel
brownie I was on the strict diet regimen
I to make sure I got my [ __ ] workouts
on I walked my fat off is that what you
did I just walk you know what I always
think about that because there was a guy
in the neighborhood that I grew up in
Inc I think his name was Corey I don't
remember but he was overweight and I
think a summer past two summers passed I
hadn't seen him and he had lost like 100
pounds and I was like dude what he's
like I just stopped driving like I would
walk everywhere look so he was like you
know and it was a small town so you
could walk to the mall might take an
hour as opposed to a 10-minute Drive but
he would choose to do that he would walk
everywhere and he was like yeah I did
that and then I just stopped eating as
much fast food and Here I am there it is
I was so intrigued and I think about
that all the time because it was amazing
to me people
no man the power walking is huge
especially when you're a bigger guy like
I forgot where I read this but the
reason why I started walking well I got
into this whole thing about David
Goggins but I calculated on average how
many calories you burn per height and
weight when you walk so if you're up so
if you're above like 200 pounds or 185
pounds like you burn about like a
hundred and ten calories per mile that
you walk Wow
so it gets less and less we get smaller
right so I was you're carrying more
weight on you it's more it's more of
effort
yes I was like 270 pounds I was like
burning like a hundred fifty calories
per mile so I was walking like four or
five miles a day she liked actually
going out and walking or were you on a
treadmill I go out I go out open my
mouth catch flies I think people just
thought I was lost I just catch a flies
what are you what are you doing the one
thing I don't know I just opened my
mouth and I walk around I'm just a mouth
breather in the whole neighborhood I'm
home yo P I'm telling ya I'm just mouth
breathing walking through the whole
[ __ ] neighborhood you realize oh my
god I just slowly started becoming that
creepy dude in the neighborhood that
people didn't know that was skinnier you
know the look where's that fat guy I
don't know that's [ __ ] a newer
skinnier guy but I would legit do that
[ __ ] because I think so much I need a
time not to think yes I would do that in
my wasp right would just I would
literally shut my [ __ ] brain off and
the catch flies with my mouth open dude
just [ __ ] that [ __ ] oh my god but four
to five miles that's a lot of walking
yeah and I needed it because I needed
time for me to just be away from things
and this was during the time I was
struggling with what I wanted to be
because I just finished the film and I
gained weight for the film by the way
and then so I
I had to lose the weight obviously for
health reasons I just really was out of
shape dear and at a certain point like
like I said this on my pockets before I
didn't know I was fat like nobody told
me no part of you was like oh maybe a
little I don't know if I was I knew I
was overweight yeah and I was sad I was
fat like I was a fat fat guy you know
what I mean like a really fat guy like
I'm like the dude that you walk by as
you're walking you're like he has poor
poor life choices now I was a bad guy
but I would look at other fat people
like look at this fat [ __ ] you yeah
change your life I'm like but you're
fatter than me and I'm like yeah so I
didn't know like how large I was getting
Wow but then you know when your knees
start sounding like bubble wrap just
popping and [ __ ] and then yo my knees
are [ __ ] up right now dude cuz I used
to play a lot of basketball and also
starch and then you know as a big guy
you played ball your cartilage starts to
wear out yeah and I didn't know about
this stuff but I tore my I tore my
meniscus I fractured both my ankles
playing basketball you know I've
actually had less injuries doing Muay
Thai and kickboxing than I did doing
basketball yeah so after a while I just
started to you know get that [ __ ]
together and then that kind of helped me
organize my life as I was doing these
walks because it would teach me to break
into a habit so it's like you can do
this every day if you can walk your fat
ass a mile every day that's all you need
to do [ __ ] losing the way part just show
it show yourself that you could do
something consistently right so I and
during this time it was raining a lot it
was like oh my god so I would say if it
rained I was like [ __ ] it boy get up get
your ass up and [ __ ] start walking so
even though it would be raining I would
just walk in the rain and I remember one
time I was walking in the rain and I
wasn't checking my weight at all and I
was like oh [ __ ] this was the second day
second day I walked in the rain and I
kind of like wait teared up a little
because I was like yo man you're [ __ ]
doing this dude like yeah it doesn't
matter you're still going to do this
[ __ ] and I just sat there and I was like
almost like lightweight like patting
myself on my fat man this year and the
next thing you know the first month I
think I lost like a pound or two yeah
and then I started changing my my eating
habits a little bit I researched like
what foods were good for you how you
should eat no no extreme dieting
yeah and just portion controlling and
eating healthy foods that are good for
you and they see you next month ten
pounds then another 20 pounds then 30
pounds and the next thing you know like
I was like oh [ __ ] I'm getting thin and
I didn't know this until my girlfriend
told me
at this time we weren't living together
so she would see me every week and I
only see it on the weekends she's like
what's going on who are you yeah right
cuz yeah your body starts to make
changes pretty quickly yeah she [ __ ]
[ __ ] she'll come out to me she's like I
could put my arms around ya say that
louder yeah that's so sweet
so she was like super obvious Lee my
support group was great my girlfriend
was always supporting you yeah she
always she never said anything about my
weight like she never said anything she
started worrying about my health a lot
aside from the fact that when I you know
call somebody else fat and she was like
you're a fat guy how dare you my doctor
said I'm an athlete wait so how much
weight did you lose total in 63 pounds
that's amazing yeah so I just checked my
weight the other day so and how long did
that take its I say that I lost the
first 50 pounds in the first ten months
and then the rest of it has been really
really really gradual now card exactly
yeah once it's honestly the the
beginning is so easy because your body
is just like it's getting used to this
act I mean it's not so easy I shouldn't
say that but once you experience it now
you're like oh [ __ ] yeah the first like
your body activates and that's what I've
been finding out from other people like
the first month or two like it some
people they lose gradual a lot of weight
some people they won't lose anything at
all but for some reason my second month
it just went boom and it all started
falling off yeah and it was the
lifestyle changes and also I think it
was your body
you gave your body time also to change
because it was like it was getting used
to it might have even started storing
fat at the beginning because it was used
to this new activity our bodies are so
weird and we never know what they're
gonna do but it's so awesome that you
were able to do that in that time span
because I feel there's also the people
who yo-yo with it where like they will
make the healthy change it's not that
you were doing any anything excessive at
all but even just something as simple as
starting to walk and make dietary
changes I feel like people will still
after four months be like okay I'm over
it you know and I stopped just there's
no race you know you just act like if
you're gonna do this
the rest of your life like yo ye it took
you [ __ ] whatever X amount of years
to get fat it's gonna take you a while
to lose that way too so just chill you
know and I start stop expecting crazy
results because my issue with like the
fitness industry was that people kept on
telling people that you could have
things instantly and right now and it
used to piss me off so that specifically
[ __ ] dudes that use roids I know who
you [ __ ] audience we all know who you
are like I know you guys meant and you
guys are selling these [ __ ] programs
to these kids saying like you'll do my 2
month program and you're gonna look just
like me yeah won't you give them your
[ __ ] tour in a ball - yeah then they
will see what'll happen right yeah but
you're not mentioning that [ __ ] and
you're telling these kids that they
could be just like you they can get
these results and they don't make it
disappointed and they gain their weight
back because they send a lot of money on
yes grams to those programs can be like
I've seen some as expensive as like $500
so that's why I really am when I was
doing Kaizen I enjoyed Kaizen because it
didn't sell you like this fake it was
numbers he goes if I do these your
numbers will increase and things will
happen this way it was very realistic
and it was a way for you to monitor what
you were doing
everything is science-based with them
and obviously like with Bart Mike and
Omar they're some of the most respected
people in the fitness industry and so
like I remember cuz I I had my own
program with Kaizen as well and so many
girls cuz I was like I'm never gonna
launch anything like this because I can
write like a basic bodybuilding program
that's problematic and controversial as
well because I'm not you know I'm not
certified in any way but I have enough
knowledge where I could write that
confidently and know that these people
are gonna get a good workout but when it
comes to like powerlifting and strength
and all of that and also like getting
just all of it I have no idea but when
people bought the program that I had
launched with them this is like two
years ago so many girls we created a
group for them and they were just like
oh my god I've never had my body like
experience these changes before I'm
getting so strong my form is amazing I
feel great and I was like the things
that you can see those are the stuff
that you can see it media exactly I mean
I see it in those numbers per se because
you keep reaching for this specific
number but you can see strength
improving you see you hit stronger ways
you know and everything else starts to
come along with it exactly if you want
to get stronger you do have to make
adjustments in your lifestyle yeah if
you want to have better endurance you
have to make those other adjustments and
so that's what I liked about that but
there's some other people where I just
see it and they're just so adamant about
like you'll be like me
this product by this thing and it'll
help you be like me like I don't have
any problems with like product placement
like cuz they all make sense
protein stuff like that oh they're all
great right you know I'm not talking
about that I'm talking about specific
dudes that sell specific programs
promise you something that they can it's
just unattainable yeah oh and it's so
prevalent in the in the fitness female
community too with butts like built a
booty in four weeks
no that does not take four weeks if you
look at any girls glute transformation
whatever that is always like years in
the making and people oh my god I don't
even know people will post pictures of
like their butts and it's like a
side-by-side and it's a testimonial but
their underwear is hiked up higher or
lifecourse shutting that you know and
it's so clearly that but when you don't
know any better and like I know because
I've been in this world for a long time
but all these other girls who have no
idea about fitness see that and they're
like oh my god okay that's gonna be me
too and then that's it all the cycle
continues and it it just it sucks I had
to show my girlfriend this this this
pose where a lot of people do it right
it's where they they twist their body
this way and it elongate their their
waistline it makes it really slam and so
she was like showing me these pictures
like look at these girls they got this I
was like hold on a second I'm gonna show
you something I said take a picture of
me right now take a picture and I
twisted I turned my by this way she was
oh my god I was like yeah that's exactly
what they're doing it's like you know
she didn't know so all she does is see
these people get these results as I'm
working hard how come I don't have this
I was like stop don't do that yeah you
know don't do I mean I'm I'm not mad at
you for it but like there's trying to
sell you want something that's not real
exactly you know like I like looking at
stuff like that it's very motivational
but just take it with the grain of salt
exactly that's all that it is you know
[ __ ] an hour 34 minutes in [ __ ] I've
been talking forever
we killed I don't even know did we do
good job we did a [ __ ] great just so
fun
don't you have you want more okay oh my
god Riley would [ __ ] himself that's the
cool thing about this my podcast like
you don't have to be anybody like I'd
love just about conversation so like
Riley will poop himself no you don't you
understand and then it's gonna be cute
I'm already calling this now he's gonna
sit down in this chair and he's gonna go
like this he's gonna push back here
that's not there and then you're gonna
go okay
I write he stutters a lot it's really
cute I'll be fine Riley you'll be great
you know I'm hanging on this [ __ ] dude
so what can they find you
young Jasmine ah yes you can find me on
youtube Jasmine Garcia you find me on
Instagram Jasmine Garcia found me on
Twitter
Jeff jazz er Garcia and you know you
might be disappointed you might not be
will not be disappointed man check out
this girl store she's [ __ ] hilarious
meso most people like I feel like when
they see somebody that is physically
attractive they kind of they're very
dismissive about their how great their
personality can be they're like this
girl just does this listen be fair some
of them don't have personality so you
have a pill battle is why I had a genius
brain podcast she's gonna be coming back
on your quite frequently cuz I [ __ ]
love talking tonight old you I'm good at
Girl Talk dude you are honestly know I
grew up in AB you supply store so that's
all I heard my whole life yep yeah so
that's my [ __ ] you know yeah I love
gossip I love when girls chat cuz
sometimes guys don't chat like this no
it's very true I mean I I have that with
Riley but like as far as my other guy
for no it's absolutely not an option at
all yes like Zoo is they don't really
like get into like specific things and I
like this type of stuff like I said when
you grow up in abusive place where this
is all the [ __ ] that you hear in the
hair salon is [ __ ] this is this is all
your hair so I grew up around the [ __ ]
so it's like well guys you can check us
out on Spotify you can check us out on
Cass box on the iTunes you can check us
everywhere else so make sure that you
guys go on there's do and then give us
that five star and if you don't want to
watch the video just go on the podcast
and listen to it on your commute we're
there for you remember check out Jasmine
one of my favorite favorite [ __ ]
Fitness influencers and everything in
this world dude you will never meet
somebody as funny as this [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] weird